CHICKEN AND NEVER EXERCISES IS
AS GOOD AS SHAPE YOU SAY HE'S
IN.
>> GENETICS.
SOME PEOPLE HAVE GREAT GENES.
I TOLD THE PRESIDENT IF HE HAD A
HEALTHIER DIET OVER THE NEXT 20
I DON'T LIMIT HIS DIET.
I MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS.
>> Reporter: SHOULD HE COMMENTS
ON THAT?
>> I MIGHT COMMENT ON MY
5-YEAR-OLD BUT HE PRESIDENT CAN
WATCH AS MUCH AS TV AS HE WANTS.
>> Sean: THAT WAS THE
PRESIDENT'S PHYSICIAN ANSWERING
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
IN
I
INSANE.
THEY NEED PSYCHOLOGICAL HELP.
HERE WITH REACTION FROM THE
TRUMP ORGANIZATION, PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S SON, ERIC TRUMP.
PART IS FUNNY BUT IT'S NOT
FUNNY.
HE PASSED A TEST
>> AND HE ACED IT.
>> 30 FOR 30.
>> IT'S INSANE.
FIRST THE ADMIRAL DID AN AMAZING
JOB.
EAT TOO MUCH ICE CREAM.
HALF THE PEOPLE IN THERE I
REMEMBER THIS FRE CAMPAIGN AND I
REMEMBER THEM SLEEP DEPRIVED
DRINKING CASES OF RED BULL THEY
COULDN'T KEEP UP.
THEY WERE NOT SPEAKING IN FOUR
DIFFERENT STATES.
THEY'RE FALLING ASLEEP, THEY
CAN'T KEEP UP WITH HIM.
MY FATHER, FIRST I'VE NEVER SEEN
THE MAN WITH A COLD.
SECOND, HE HAS MORE ENERGY THAN
ANY AMERICAN I'VE EVER MET IN MY
LIFE.
HE WILL OUT WORK ANYBODY.
HE STAYS UP -- THE GUY IS
INCREDIBLE.
>> Sean: I'VE LISTED YOUR DAD'S
ACCOMPLISHMENTS FOR THE FIRST
YEAR.
81 PROMISES MADE AND KEPT.
THESE ARE HUGE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS --
>> AND NOTHING.
>> Sean: YOU THE ECONOMIC BOOM
BEFORE OUR EYES AND THEY'RE
UPSET OUR PRESIDENT IS HEALTHY.
EXCELLENT HEALTH.
>> WITH THAT RESULT WATCH AS
MUCH AS TV AS YOU WANT.
THE DOW IS BEFORE TO BREAK
26,000.
>> Sean: IT DID TODAY.
>> YOU HAVE THE LOWEST
UNEMPLOYMENT YOU DID BEFORE AND
LOWEST AFRICAN AMERICAN
UNEMPLOYMENT AND HIGHEST
CONFIDENCE.
YOU HAD 44,000 ISIS AND THEY'RE
KILLING THEM OFF RAPIDLY.
IT'S INSANE.
>> Sean: THEY DON'T LIKE HE'S
VIEWS AND POLITICALLY INCORRECT.
>> THEY DON'T LIKE THEY WERE
WRONG.
THEY ALL GOT IT WRONG.
THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO BE THE
SMART PEOPLE AND THEY WERE THE
BRILLIANT JOURNALISTS AND GOT IT
WRONG.
HE FRANKLY EMBARRASSED THEM AND
THEY'RE DOUBLE DOWN AND HE'LL
PROVE THEM WRONG AGAIN AND
AGAIN.
IT HAPPENS TO ME EVERY DAY, I
WALK DOWN THE STREET AND PEOPLE
HUG ME TELL YOUR FATHER WE SAY
THANK YOU.
I JUST OPENED UP MY 401(k).
IT'S UP 31%.
I DIDN'T THINK RETIREMENT WAS
POSSIBLE.
>> I HATE WALL STREET.
I WISH I WAS UP 31%.
PEOPLE KNOW WE'RE NOT THEM.
I'VE ALWAYS NEVER BEEN A WHITE
SOIT
SOI
-I
--
SOIT WORKS OUT WELL.
IMAGINE WHERE THEY SAID DONALD
TRUMP RIGGED A SCANDAL AND YOUR
DAD WITH SALACIOUS LIES WON THE
GENERAL ELECTION AGAINST HILLARY
AND HIS MINIONS EXONERATED YOUR
FATHER BEFORE THE INVESTIGATION.
WANTED TO USE TO MANIPULATE THE
PEOPLE TO STEEL THE GENERAL,
BEFORE THE PRIMARY, THAT WAS
USED TO GET A WARRANT ON HILLARY
GOD WE DON'T HAVE TO SAY THAT.
>> HOW ABOUT GOING BACK TO THE
BEGINNING WHERE DONNA BRAZIL IS
GIVING THE QUESTION TO HILARY
BEFORE THE DEBATE.
THERE'D BE NOTHING LEFT LEFT
ALONE THE FAKE DOSSIERS AND
HERE'S A REALITY OF WHAT
HAPPENED.
WORKED MUCH HARDER DESPITE
HAVING ONE-SEVENTH THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY WHO BLEW THE OTHER PERSON
OUT OF THE WATER.
THEY NEED AN EXCUSE.
THEY NEEDED A WAY TO JUSTIFY
THEIR LOSS.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY RIGHT NOW, THEY HAVE NO
MESSAGE, NO LEADERSHIP
>> Sean: NOTHING.
AND NO VISION TO HELP THE
FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN OF THIS
COUNTRY.
YOU KNOW THE BEST THING YOUR
DAD, HE GIVES A SPEECHES OR TOWN
HALLS, THE PEOPLE IN THE BACK,
FAKE NEWS AND EVERYBODY TURNS
AND THEY'RE SCREAMING AT PEOPLE
IN THE MEDIA AND SAY YOU SUCK.
>> THINK OF HAVING AN APPROVAL
RATING CLOSE TO THE MEDIA'S
APPROVAL RATING, SINGLE DIGITS.
WOULDN'T YOU WANT TO CHANGE
COURSE?
LOOK AT CNN'S RATINGS.
IF SOMETHING'S NOT WORKING WOULD
YOU WANT TO CHANGE COURSE THAN
DOUBLES DOWN AND DOUBLING DOWN.
>> Sean: 195 TIMES THEY SAID
I'M SORRY, THEY SAID I COULDN'T
SAY IT AND IT'S PIRS
SAY IT AND IT'S PISSIN
SAY IT AND IT'S PISSING
SAY IT AND IT'S PISSING ME
SAY IT AND IT'S PISSING ME O
SAY IT AND IT'S PISSING ME OFF
SAY IT AND IT'S PISSING ME OFF.
>> THEY DIDN'T MENTION THE DOW
HITTING 26,000 AND THINGS
IMPORTANT TO THE NATION.
ONE THING I'LL TAKE AWAY IS THE
MEDIA DOES NOT UNDERSTAND -- AT
LEAST THE VAST MAJORITY, DOESN'T
UNDERSTAND THE VOICE OF THE
COUNTRY.
AND L.A.
SIX PEOPLE AT THE VERY TOP
WHO --
>> Sean: AND THEY SAID THEY CARE
ABOUT THE MEN AND WOMEN ON
POVERTY OUT OF WORK, AT ANY
POINT DOES THEY LOOK AT SECURITY
OR IT WAS DUMB FOR OBAMA TO
BRIBE MURDERS TO LIKE US.
AND A CARGO PLANE WITH
OCCURRENCE FROM A MILLION
COUNTRIES.
>> EVERYONE'S COMPLAINING WITH
THE WALL BUT THEY'RE WILLING TO
GIVE MILLIONS TO IRAN.
>> Sean: IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
YOU CAN TAKE IT, YOUR BROTHER
CAN TAKE IT AND YOUR SISTER CAN
TAKE IT AND JARED CAN TAKE IT
THEN THEY PICK ON THE FIRST LADY
AND YOUR 11-YEAR-OLD BROTHER AND
THEY DON'T EVEN SEE THAT AS
BEING WRONG.
>> THERE ARE NO BOUNDARIES.
THERE'S NO BOUNDARIES.
IT'S ALMOST THE WORST OF
HUMANITY.
YOU DON'T GO OVER A 12-YEAR-OLD
CHILD.
>> Sean: IS HE 12?
>> AROUND THERE.